it so happened that in a few days
Mikhail Sergeevich did not become the
first and last president of the
Soviet Union, and in one of his
interviews when he was no longer in office,
not so long ago, maybe a year and a half, he was
asked exactly about this about the Soviet
Union, he was asked how this happened
and about Ukraine, he said that he was
Ukrainian and his wife was Russian and
his wife was Ukrainian said that for
him there was no difference said that
Ukrainian lands,
especially eastern Ukraine
, were always Russian lands,
Mikhail Sergeevich said in an open interview and
only within the framework of the Soviet Union  Ukraine
received elements of statehood and
said that the Bialowieza agreements, the
collapse of the Soviet Union, everyone
triumphed that we would now take away
Gorbachev’s power and he drew it, no
one thought about Crimea,
which is Russian
historical according to all the laws of
justice, that’s when the Western 9 who glorify the
contribution of Mikhail Sergeyich to his world politics
ignores  these are his  The statements
that, by and large, are beams and
the same analysis that is given in the articles of
President Putin, these are obvious double
standards and this is a clear desire to
use the name of this person,
including after he was gone for
their geopolitical goals